how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in double thank you and welcome to
being human and being good most of us
like the idea of being good or at least
being seen to be good or many of us
think that being moral is an essential
part of being human and that's the
question that we're going to be
addressing today is being moral an
essential part of being human
because what we take to be good differs
from person to person culture to culture
well we have with us a very
distinguished panel to debate this very
salient topic simone schnell is director
of the cambridge body mind and behavior
laboratory ray lankton is the knight
bridge professor of philosophy at
cambridge and head of faculty there and
joel robbins is a american social
anthropologist and he's written widely
about the morality in Papua New Guinea
society so is morality just a story that
we tell ourselves or is it something
that describes an objective set of rules
out there so let me begin first of all
with Simone is morality just the story
absolutely not it's very much part of
the social fabric the fabric of society
it is something that we process whenever
we meet somebody for the first time we
do that within milliseconds we decide
whether for example somebody is
trustworthy so it's one of the first
things we want to assess in terms of
wanting to engage with a person or not
staying away from them so it's it's
clear in my mind it's not just a story
it's something very very profound
and in that context I'd like to refer
some work that I find quite influential
by Robin Dunbar he's proposed what he
calls the social brain hypothesis and
with that he says that well for one
thing the brain evolved to keep track of
social relationship social situations
and more specifically the people that we
close to people that we can trust and he
proposes that language in fact evolved
as a means of keeping track of
reputations keeping track of who's the
good guy who's the bad guy who you
should avoid who you should not engage
with because they might be liars
cheaters murderers and so on so he's
basically saying that language evolved
for the purpose of gossip
so gossip being the idea that as a
community we keep track of people's
reputations and I think nowadays
reputations are more important than ever
or they're more relevant than ever if we
think of the ways in which information
now can be spread so it's not just word
of mouth or you whispering to somebody
that you know in the same way as we
otherwise might but now of course we all
have that megaphone of social media
these kind of and these pieces of
information can spread in no time and
they can be quite destructive so it's
it's very much a reality it's not just a
story that we tell ourselves thank you
see man right
I agree with Simone that morality is not
just a story we tell ourselves though I
do agree we do tell lots of stories to
ourselves and lots of our stories about
our own motivations might be fabricated
but our morality is not just about the
social fabric either and here's where I
might part ways with Simone it
transcends both the social and it
transcends the individual so morality is
the point at which we get to think about
someone other than ourselves we get to
think we get to escape the prison of the
self and think about what's going on in
other people and what matters to them
and although hilary mentioned that
morality is different all over the world
and there are many different moral
practices first of all we need to
distinguish what people take morality to
be and what morality is so what we take
morality to be is one thing and
sometimes that might be mistaken and
what morality is might be another and
sometimes we might get it right
sometimes not in fact at some points
morality is going to involve factors
that are common across many different
cultures I'll just mention despite the
agreement about that many diverse
practices there are certain common
threads one common thread that is there
in morality as it is and in morality as
a social practice is a commitment to
something like empathy something like
putting yourself in other people's shoes
something like understanding how things
are from the viewpoint of someone else
that's there in Buddhist views about
compassion it's there in the golden rule
that says do unto others as you would
have them do unto you it's there and
that golden rule by the way has versions
in nearly every major religion Jesus
wasn't the first to utter it
it was also also there in Judaic
principles before that and there are
versions of it in Chinese ethics and
philosophy Taoism and elsewhere as well
and I'm no anthropologist I'm a
philosopher but I want to put I do want
to suggest that there is a common thread
which involves
a willingness to step outside the step
self and realize that other people
matter in the way that we do now it's
sometimes called the golden rule this
gets to the second part of the statement
but I actually don't think it is so much
a rule as a matter of a way of
understanding how things are for other
people understanding which begins with
our friends and family and then goes
further Aristotle said that a friend is
another self and you can understand
things that are going on with with your
friends and what matters to them and you
care about that and do things that are
in their interest that's where morality
begins with people that are close to us
and in a way morality is about expanding
that circle so that that kind of
understanding goes much further it's not
so much a rule as a kind of
understanding which helps us motivate
ourselves to do something more than we
otherwise would do thank you Joe
Thanks so we've been asked an either/or
question is morality just a story we
tell ourselves or as a set of rules we
have to follow and I'm gonna do a kind
of old trick and answer yes to be
either/or question I think it's both it
is a story and we do have to follow the
rules so the sense in which it's a story
is that for everyone their own sense of
what counts as moral as how you be a
human being as how you relate to others
beyond yourself is absolutely shaped by
the culture they they grow up in the
culture they live around the stories
that they're exposed to whatever
intuitions they may have on a pan human
level instincts or impulses that those
only make sense to people through the
cultural stories that they have and they
only know how to express them
effectively to others around them
through various cultural templates we
also know it's a story in that in the
sense that very broad sense we're using
it because it really does vary across
cultures and it can vary pretty
extensively so just to put some
anthropology on the table and we'd have
to discuss it in more length what it
means but it's it's found in a lot of
Papua New Guinea societies there are 700
languages in New Guinea so
you can't generalize for everyone a very
strong view that you can never know
what's going on in another person's mind
it's absolutely it's actually impossible
but it's also very unethical to try and
it's completely unethical ever to
verbalize what somebody else might be
thinking and so certainly empathy
they're very strong on sympathy on
feeling for another person on saying if
I were in that situation I would feel
terrible and so I feel bad for you but
but if we take empathy to be feeling
with another person that's actually
profoundly unethical there and people
then we have studies of little children
who do spontaneously try to do that
being taught you don't do that that's
not something we do so the differences
go quite quite deep so it is a story the
second half of the question are the
rules we have to follow most people in
their own lives are Hilary use the
phrase moral realists in their own lives
they think their moral rules are are
substantial and real and and binding
they're binding in the sense not that
you have to follow them but that in you
know that you know and this comes back
to Simone's point about reputation that
if you don't follow them you will be
judged for them you're subject to
evaluation you have to orient to the
rules that are out there in your
surrounding world in order to function
as a social creature do you don't always
have to be good that's why gossip is
interesting but you do you do to become
to be a social person and to survive as
a social person you have to orient to
the rules so they are stories they are
stories that we tell ourselves but we
also live with them as real socially
speaking because that's how we make
lives together get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in aaaggghhh